Beth just doesn't hold back ever you
know he is in a very reactionary kind of
place and she's fighting she's just
constantly fighting there are plenty of
moments where I think I can't believe
she's gonna do this but it makes it
makes sense
yep everyone's favorite foul mouth sassy
Dutton daughter is back with a vengeance
I'm something bad Kelly Riley's
character Beth finally said I do to rip
but she's far from having her happily
ever after this season airing Sundays on
the Paramount Network repeat after me I
best up yes I do no
um not yet what is in store for The
Newlywed this season there is some
scenes where Beth enjoys the cowboy life
a little bit which um with rip and it's
uh it's a lot of fun to see Beth
um try that on for for feels and she
loves it absolutely loves it come on we
can go have some fun
partying for me it is
it's for everyone so it sounds like Beth
as a person she is evolving now that
she's married and now in season five
will we see Beth allow herself to be
happier you know Taylor Sheridan writes
this show and it's full of drama and
struggle right so I don't think I've
said this before but I don't think a
happy birth is necessarily uh you know
great fodder for entertainment uh we
sort of thrive on her
um you know on her reactions to things
so um maybe I hope one day I hope we've
just sewn the seeds a little bit for
what that might look like for her
um but she's you know she's got people
to fight she's got bad guys to get you
know she's going to save a ranch for her
dad so
um I don't think any time soon is she
gonna be hanging that up but I hope so
we would love I would love Beth to find
sort of forgiveness but that's not the
show it's not the character and Taylor's
right that's not and so it's an
interesting you know that we all want to
be able to say what the ending should be
or what these characters should do or
say but that's also part of the fun of
watching it we're seeing uh Finn Little
AKA Carter back in the bunk house and
it's amazing how no one is recognized
him because he just has this growth
spurt right so does this mean that rip
and Beth have a teenager on their hands
and how does that test there yeah he's
not so little anymore uh Finn um so we
we had a year
Hiatus filming so in that year I don't
know what he ate or what happened to him
but the hormones kicked in and we now
have a man
um so yeah there is a teenager
um whose voice is dropped he's grown
like three feet and has facial hair it's
just suddenly overnight there he is and
it was a joke because all of us couldn't
recognize him so they sort of I think
Taylor wrote that in
um but it's so lovely to see his
development and yes it seems like
um Beth and rip now have a teenager
under their roof yeah you want those
things
work really really
did Kelly Riley love the cowboy life
it's it's my favorite part of the job
Beth doesn't ride horses right she had a
terrible riding accident when she was
younger and it caused the death of her
mother
um by her fear of Horses The Beth has
now decided never to be afraid of
anything ever again she does that quite
successfully so she she had a little bit
of a ride on a horse with Walker early
on and sort of made a little bit more
peace but they're all going off on this
Castle ride and uh to get this sort of
yearly event which is really um
wonderful and Beth is going to be left
alone in the house and she's like well
that's not going to happen
um so she decides that she's going to go
with them and um
they go off camping for a night I loved
it because I get to be on the back of a
horse and I get to put on some chaps and
a cowboy hat and I get to be riding in
that Countryside and that under in those
mountains there was one day where we
were filming in the middle of nowhere
you had to get on a Gator for like 20
minutes up of a mountain and uh it was
uh and it was worth it because you just
had the look like the ride down to the
um throughout the valley and the views
and it was idyllic and gorgeous and at
the end of the day
um all the Cowboys would take your
horses and they would ride them down to
the hill down to the back it took about
an hour and a half two hours to ride
back and I decided to I wanted to ride
back
instead so I didn't let them take my
horse so I rode back with all the real
cowboys not the actor pretend Cowboys
the real ones and um and they really are
the real ones and got to see the
Magnificent Sunset
um and backdrop and I just I just
couldn't take the smile off my face I
loved it so much
see in season five any type of amends
being made between Beth and Jamie or is
that tension gonna still be at an
all-time high well it's getting more
complicated
um and it's certainly a huge part of
this season
Beth and Jamie are now you know he's
back in the fold of the family that she
has you know she says in this first
episode you're in my prison now
you will do what he asks you to do and
he um that's how you will stay within
this family by doing as we ask I mean
it's kind it's awful but you know Jamie
in in Beth's mind Jamie was
um part of the reason there was a hit on
the whole family tried to kill her
father tried to kill her tried to kill
everybody her brother Casey so in her
mind he is the enemy so it is that I do
think in best mind it is keep your
enemies really close and that's what
she's doing she's got her eye on him
um I can't tell you what happens at the
end of the season but um yeah I don't
think there's going to be any uh
peaceful ending between between them two
not yet anywhere I don't see I'm gonna
run everything aren't you
everything
you miserable
for me Kelly it's um it's sometimes
um it's a little dive off the deep end I
had to train for a couple of the Epic
scenes in in this season now was that
physical training yes wow okay so Beth
really is gonna amp up the level yeah in
a kind of old school way I don't know
what the reaction is going to be and
that's half of the the fear and the
excitement because our fans are so
passionate and they're so invested for
me are they gonna go with her or are
they gonna sort of Abandon Ship maybe
that's too far
ruin them starting with her Jackie
Weaver and her team have made it a
mission to take Beth down is Beth scared
no that's not scared right no that's not
scared of of her no
uh I think Beth is afraid that that the
ranch is threatened I think Beth is um
is always trying to come up with
ways to them over and to try and sorry
about my language sorry um
um
to defend the land and to defend it for
her father and that is sort of her
reason to be right now and so she will
she won't stop at anything and nobody
will get in her way and Beth plays dirty
she said that
um she admits that this season there is
some interesting moments it's juicy
do you think season five will be the end
no I don't know when the end will be but
I don't think season season five is not
is is not our ending at least I hope not
[Music]